[Music]  Alyssia vikander and Michael Fassbender  is showing some serious skin in Spain  I'll just take the attention  check out the insanely bit couple  yachting with friends on Wednesday forty  year old Michael shirtless in his Navy  swim trunks and 26 year old vikander and  a burgundy polka-dotted bikini her abs  on full display and we're loving her  braided ponytail yes young cemetry my  thing business is I'm trying to take it  all in the pair has been vacationing in  Europe all week just funny et was with  Michael in May talking to the actor  about Alicia taking on the role of Lara  Croft in Tomb Raider the first photos of  Tomb Raider been released it looks  amazing how is your light between oceans  co-star settling into Lara Croft I think  you know she's taking to it like a duck  to water  [Music]  you